what's up guys bang bang i'm in la this
weekend but you didn't think i was going
to forget about our weekly conversation
around bitcoin metrics did you let's
dive into this week huge week lots of
data to unpack here we go so first if we
take a look bitcoin's been hovering
right around 43 500 there's a lot of
different assets across the world that
are all starting to suffer see s p gold
silver euro yen and rnb all going down
if we then go ahead and look at the
actual bitcoin specific stats we're
sitting right around 825 billion dollar
market cap still a massive asset that's
only been around for about 13 years the
inflation rate unchanged at 1.77 percent
and over 90 percent of the bitcoin
supply has been issued one of the stats
that i continue to look at is what is
that settlement volume doing still 12
billion or so in that 24 hour settlement
volume that means people are using it
that means that bitcoin still has value
then active addresses over 1 million
which is a huge number and one that we
need to continue to watch seeing that
more people are using the bitcoin
network means that the underlying
fundamentals continue to have value
gbtc now down to about a 10 discount and
obviously bitcoin down 36 percent from
the all-time high but up 31 from the
cycle low it's exactly what you want to
see now one of the things that hasn't
been normal over the last two years or
so is bitcoin actually being down over
the last 12 months if you go ahead and
we look here at the bitcoin versus gold
and the s p 500 only bitcoin is down
over the last year it's down six percent
gold even is up half a percent the s p
500 is up 15
bitcoiners aren't used to saying that
bitcoins down over a year but other
assets are up but that situation that we
find ourselves in if you then go and you
look over a two three four five six
seven eight nine or ten year period
bitcoin absolutely dominated the return
profile and so really just that last 12
months something that bitcoiners haven't
been used to talking about now if we go
ahead and we look at bitcoin's price
closing history by level 43 500 or so
only 240 days of all of bitcoin's
history has been spent above that level
so five percent of the time we've been
above the level 95 of bitcoin's life
we've been spending below that level
which means that if you bought 95 of
that time and you held till today you're
in the money then if we go and we look
at actually some of the more nuanced
data around bitcoin and gold s p nasdaq
and tlt the one i always jump to is what
is that compound annual growth rate over
the last 10 years bitcoin's still
growing at 148
every single year compounded for a
decade that's exactly why people hold
bitcoin for very long periods of time
then if we jump and look at some of the
underlying fundamentals around mining
you can see that sam roll pulled up the
bitcoin hash rate and when he looks at
that mean hash rate on this moving seven
day average what you can see is that it
continues to be around all-time highs
bitcoin is getting stronger and stronger
and stronger that huge dip here in the
chart is when china banned the bitcoin
miners kicked him out of the country and
then the hash rate came back with a
vengeance the bitcoin hash rate has
grown almost 9
this year in 2022 but ultimately the
most important thing is that it
weathered the storm from that
nation-state attack and it came back and
hit an all-time high within about eight
months it's exactly what we want to see
is that the strongest computing network
in the world continues to get stronger
the most decentralized computing network
in the world continues to get more and
more decentralized now the most
important chart of course coming from
our friend will clemente talking about
illiquid supply and these supply shock
ratios we've been talking about this now
for 18 months or so
when you start to look at what people
are doing
lots of people are buying bitcoin and
they have a history of not selling
that's where you get this illiquid
supply continuing to grow faster and
faster and faster almost 80
of bitcoin supply being held by people
who have a history of not selling
similar to what we saw in the summer of
2021 and when all of those people are
buying bitcoin and they're holding it
and they're not willing to sell all of a
sudden you get a little increase in
demand and price has to go up to
accommodate everyone i'm not saying
that's exactly what's going to happen in
the short term but what i can say is
that the illiquid supply continues to go
higher and higher it provides a market
dynamic that simply forces the price
higher as more people continue to adopt
decentralized digital
censorship-resistant currency all right
i hope that that was helpful we don't
have all the answers but these weekly
conversations help me unpack what's
going on in the market and help me just
think through more clearly as to what
could possibly happen in the future the
big news this week was obviously that
inflation came in at 7.5 percent the
highest it's been in 40 years people
around the world whether they're
individuals organizations financial
institutions or nation states they're
all trying to figure out how the hell do
i protect my purchasing power how do i
protect the economic value that i
created well bitcoin is one of those
solutions and it continues to chug along
block after block after block of
transactions bitcoin doing exactly what
it was designed to do hope you guys have
a great rest of your weekend and i'll
see you guys next week